i can sit and stare those are two of my
special skills on my resume
sitting and staring and i drive a stick
shift
and i know a little french okay staring
i've always promised that i'll stare but
i'll i'll
fully include
jeff
i'm going to ask you the questions and
what would be fantastic is if you repeat
the question no no you don't need to you
will not repeat it
social video people like it a little bit
choppy a little bit messy but if you
could answer straight down the camera
yeah i have eyeballs that wander but
that's fine but you know i'll as best i
can i'll include the viewer okay are you
happy to start i i if i were any happier
i'd need a wipe of some kind
wow
jeff how did you first get into acting i
was
i got the bug of some kind hello well
that's the universe telling us
okay i'm going to start again here's
what happened um like i say it i i just
got a strange bug
for it when i was 10-ish as i remember
my my um
mom
used to take my
sister and i as i remember to um uh we
grew up in pittsburgh outside of
pittsburgh in a suburb and there was a
children's theater
program and just seeing that
i was um
you know
i was excited and transfixed by it and
thought what are those people doing what
are they doing backstage you know what's
this all about but i was excited and
kind of jazzed up and then around
that that year around that year i think
i went to chatham music day camp this
may be more information than you want to
know and there was a drama program
uh amongst all the other things i love
that whole camp and anyway they gave me
a part in this
little show
and i jumped on stage when it was our
turn after i'd rehearsed for a week or
so before at home and i had to sing and
dance it was called bell of the balkans
i i had so much fun that afterwards they
said how'd you like it my parents were
there they said how'd you like that i
was like
uh
i did
and i kept secret to myself you know uh
that i had actually decided i think i
want to be an actor and then i went to
this college six week program between
ninth and tenth and tenth and eleventh
grades when i was what four fourteen or
fifty or something like that had a
a marvelous time i was totally turned on
by it uh in fact one day i came home
talking like i never had my dad said to
my mom in my presence hey i think the
kid is stimulated the kid is which fella
and i knew it was important what he was
saying and at that point i became
obsessed with it i know there's a much
longer winded answer than anyone
obsessed with it and i take a shower
every morning that's certainly more
information but we had a glass door and
would steam up and i'd say please god
let me be an actor i would write on and
then before i left i would wipe it off
because i still didn't want anybody to
know and then right after high school
moved to new york city and studied with
a great acting teacher at sandy meisner
anyway uh hilarity ensued after that and
that's what happened
you've got a very unique style of acting
and it's something that a lot of people
on the internet love a unique style yeah
me okay is that something from a very
young age you think was present or is
that something that developed as you
became older and more comfortable well
that says that's a deep and interesting
question all to call and i think
my mind is inflamed with uh what you've
suggested but um i'll try to put out the
major part of the fire and give you a
few juicy embers here's what here's what
happened hey i was interested in
clothing early on for one reason or
another i don't know why i had a little
talented art and i remember during a
certain period in art i used to always
draw
collars men's shirts and ties i was
interested i didn't want to be a
clothing designer or anything but i was
kind of interested in it and i and
around that time this is like the mid
60s and the latest styles kind of
changed so i kind of went to my glide
because i needed glasses i went and i
said of all there was one pair amongst
all the things that looked like that and
i went back to something that i liked
like that but i said give me those john
lennon glasses i wanted some of those
round wire frames and then i went to new
york and started acting and i i not only
work from and was taught to work from
the inside out but also the outside in
and if you get the right pair of shoes
it may be a you know
a portal into what your character
is um and how he might feel and walk
well sandy meisner also said that you
know not to copy anybody
and uh and uh
hopefully if you study my if you follow
this course
through the next 20 years and uh and
your life if you get chances to practice
you'll find something of your
voice that you know
might be
your own
anyway you know i did that and over the
course of uh of getting thankfully
getting chances to practice and try
things out i
found things and i mean in fact i feel
on the threshold
of uh more self-possession
and trust in my
self and instincts and like that if if
you know what i'm talking about
a lot of the our audience
will know you from the kind of memes the
gifts do you look at that stuff or do
you just let it pass you by and think
they can do what they want fans are so
sweet they're sweet when they come up
and it's nice when they do little funny
pictures i like you know pictures and we
did an episode in a world according to
jeff goldblum where i went to a tattoo
parlor where they were giving out jeff
goldblum tattoos and i participated in
that anyway that's all i kind of get a
kick out of it if you want to know the
truth and people are generally so sweet
and
hey guy
that i i look at it i look at it for a
little bit and uh it's uh it's uh fun
and sweet you know we actually realized
after we'd set up that the sound man has
a
a sticker of your face on his
i know i see i know that sticker yes
okay well thanks
thank you i take that as a great uh
coming from you high praise indeed the
first time i saw you was the fly and i
was like this guy's a horror actor and
then there's jurassic park which is
action you've got stuff like thor which
is more comedy superhero how do you
manage to as in your words inhabit
yourself while
not getting typecast wow very deep
question and interesting and we could i
could probably talk and riff on that for
too long a time but
um
you know
what you make me think of is my appetite
for variety because i think uh
you know to get better that's what i'm
trying to do i still consider myself a
humble student of uh
you know pretending and uh acting uh you
know you want to do different things
different than things than you've done
and from each other and you know just to
interest yourself and maybe other people
you want to do
surprising things unexpected things and
diff different things
yet at the same time
even though you're
the idea i think is that
is that the the approach that he
recorded that sandy being recommended
all those years ago is that even though
you may uh have a limp and a an
eye patch or a dialect
and and you may you certainly want to
explore if it's in you if that's the
kind of actor that you
that you might be explore your ability
to characterize and to jettison your
straight behavior so called and and i
like doing that i like that part of
acting and
uh it's always he would say
made up of essentially
um parts of your own gizzard you know
so that that's the approach that i'm
still tinkering with and trying to
develop
you're often called a scene stealer you
know minor roles that you have a massive
impact in in the film
is that something you aim for
no i don't aim to steal anything i'm not
a thief of any kind i uh you know uh
what does sting say
another one of your uh you know favorite
sons who whom i admired terrifically if
you love something
set it free something like that anyway
you don't want to snatch snatch anything
or or like that and i and sandy meisner
once again um
did um
[Music]
celebrate
and uh encourage us toward the ensemble
spirit
and uh
and technology whereby
you know the better the other person is
the better you are and what you do is
dependent in some way
especially spontaneously like our jazz
like my jazz endeavors you know by
listening actually being available to
what's going on around you uh and then
opening up in
reaction to that somehow uh you ain't
trying to take anything or steal
anything you're just trying to tell a
story and have a an interesting
experience the as intimate and
rich as you can have with your fellow
practitioner
so that that's what i'm after and then
the chips fall however they do and the
story gets told and
people are interested in one thing or
another but that's that's that's my aim
we have a a big audience that's global
congratulations thank you very much it's
not mine it's not bibles but what to do
now i'm getting shy but if you were
talking to if you were talking to our
sort of like big audience and you were
saying you know if you if you're going
to watch one jeff goldblum film which is
the one that you go i nailed that
well i would never i would never use
those
that language jeez i nailed that
i don't think i would i hate myself
afterwards if i uttered that that thing
oh you know well like i i've been saying
and i'm not just pretending i'm trying
to get better so i think the more recent
things are
i might prefer seeing sometimes i'll
tell you the truth i see older things
and i guess it comes with the territory
of trying to get better but i see them
and i go
you know i can get a kick out of it i'm
not just neurotic about it but sometimes
i go
i could do that better i think i know
how to do that better so so if i were
going to recommend and show anything to
anybody you know it would be more recent
things and not just because i'm pitching
it at this point um but i tell you this
i saw it we haven't seen with an
audience i'm looking forward to seeing
it tonight with an audience for the
first time and taking my kids to see it
for the first time in a movie theater
that's the first movie they will have
seen um i like this jurassic world
dominion that's what i would say to look
at first and then then you can delve
into any of the wes anderson movies
because i'll tell you it's my theory and
not some and this is not so crazy
everybody thinks the same thing that you
can't be good unless it's a good
director unless you're working with a
good durian the whole thing works and
sure enough wes anderson is a genius and
you know i like being in all those and
those are enjoyable full whole
holy successful movies creatively i do
believe um so you know there's this and
that hey you could take a look at the
fly if you want to
um
you know there you go are there any
roles you passed on that you would have
loved to have taken in hindsight
that's a good and naughty question
uh and i'm gonna be discreet about it
because you know if you pass on
something and then somebody else takes
it
they may not want to hear
yeah yeah that was my leavings you know
that's no good but there was one
that you know i i i can't i can sort of
torture myself with recrimination about
one thing or another but i'm getting
better over the years and so even a
thing like that i can go
no you know what it turned out to the
best here i am and it's all all fine and
who knows if you pull one thread of what
might have been it could have upset the
whole
thing right just like jimmy stewart and
it's a wonderful life or something like
that uh but uh or any of those time
travel movies so i wouldn't have wanted
to do it any differently but there was
one movie that i had a moment or my mat
actually my manager my manager for now
30 years said um he says if there was
one thing i think i misled you on the i
wish we'd done that but anyway i don't
know that would have made a difference
but you and i when we go to get off
camera i'll tell you an interesting
story are there any actors that you
would love to star alongside
that you have not yet we acted with yes
oh to understand stan
i mean nick cage is so interesting and i
saw him and did you see mandy yeah
yeah you did it's fun
i thought that was interesting i got a
big kick out of that yeah he i'd like to
work with him and in that vein
christopher walken we've done four
movies together but never had a scene
together
how about al pacino i've never worked
with al pacino wouldn't that be dreamy
uh robert de niro
uh you know anyway there are just a ton
of actors oh i have worked with a little
bit kate blanchett
oh my gosh i saw her on stage do
um
blanche dubois
in streetcar named desire in brooklyn
and i've seen that
on stage i've seen the movie
that was the best blanched wife i've
ever seen she's i'm deeply starstruck
with her
you know they're just a lot of people
hey you know kristen stewart
gosh
i think she's wonderful i think she's
wonderful and tilda swinton
is wonderful anyway there you go there's
a few you said earlier that you're
always trying to develop you're trying
to improve i am what's next what's what
would you like to do what's the next one
year five years
oh my god
well
at this point
um
i'm appreciating every single moment and
paradoxically maybe on one hand if
nothing were to happen after this
i'd be happy as a clam and fully
satisfied at least i aspire to that kind
of
acceptance uh i'm deeply appetized
because i'm freer than ever i tell you
i'm my i i'm enjoying myself more than
ever and so i'm appetized to do
many things and you know i like surprise
so i wouldn't want to
order it from the menu i'd say to the
chef you know i trust you
to bring me whatever you recommend and
uh surprise me
ben thank you so much i appreciate it i
appreciate all all your attention thank
you
i like that sound of the
show it's my favorite sound in life i
don't know why okay great
you can never really be true friends
after something like that i just don't
think it can ever ever happen maybe if
you
fought and it was a draw
maybe you could still be friends but the
idea of being friends with someone that
has a beating you it's a hard thing for
your head to compute